[Music]
one of my net runners is unresponsive
in spite of clear orders to remain in
direct
contact with me something must have
happened
he would not dare go against me
familiarize yourself with the brief and
proceed
swiftly i need him
[Music]
look it's you in the near future
every nip runner ends up the same way
brain fried by some corporal ice
looks like he's still breathing
now
uh
two seconds
wait i i can't
wake up
give me one moment
i don't know how long i hear but
as you americans say i'm starving
oh you're in luck there's a restaurant
upstairs
i know the whole time those aromas
what torture so you were conscious
partially more like in deep hibernation
you switch on the lights yes i was ready
for a game of
twice for yes once for now but you beat
me to it
fine work you did
so you're probably wondering who sent me
wakako she always find an excuse to drag
me to her place
for dinner you must visit me someday
i'll show you a few net running tricks
wasn't it me who just saved your ass
we never stop learning hard lessons but
you don't have to do everything
alone thanks i'll think about it
i was informed of how you handled
yourself
good work i expected nothingness from
you
i am closing the contract
foreign